in this course you will learn how to
build a weather application using react
and the open weather api
with locations that autocomplete you
will learn how to use two apis to get
and display the weather for anywhere in
the world slobodan teaches this course
he is a senior front-end developer and
experienced course creator make sure to
leave a comment with something you learn
in this course let's jump right in let
me share my screen
okay first uh i want to explain where
you can get the api keys for both of
these apis and what you need to install
what you need to register first for
because under my previous tutorials
there were a couple of apis tutorials
where you guys were struggling to find
api keys so the first one that we want
to use is on the rapid api website the
links will be in the description so
don't worry about that
you need to to create account here
on this website and
go to the
to this uh specific api the link is
going to be in the description again and
you need to subscribe to
to this api in order to test it once you
subscribe to it
you can choose what what you want to
test so you can click on the cities
because we will need the series for our
web application
then you can choose what code you want
to be generated for you you can i i
choose javascript and fetch
so you get the fetch method here and you
get the options uh parameters which are
required so the first one is the key and
here you get the generated key which is
for your account and the host
and then the the full url and how you
retrieve and map the data so it's really
useful here are all the parameters that
you can use optional ones and the
required ones
so yeah it's very useful so this is the
first api the second one is the the
actual uh weather api so you need to go
open weather website link again in the
description you need to sign up here
everything is free you don't have to pay
for anything so just go to your account
you can click on your account here and
you can go to my services to check what
apis you have available for free
and you can go and open api keys
and here you can get your api key please
register for your account and use my
mine probably i'm going to blur this
anyways but yeah you should use your api
key now that now we can go and create
our application so these are the things
that you need to do beforehand
so i open up the d drive and here i'm
going to create our react application so
run the command mpx
create
react
react
app and name of the application
uh let's name it
react
weather app
weather app and this is going to take a
couple of minutes to finish so
uh stay around with me
and finally our application has been
installed and created so we can open
that in your editor of choice for me
it's visual studio code
it's in on drive d
dev folder react feather app that one
select formula
uh first i want to install two packages
that will need in order to create this
application the first one is the
accordion that we need for the days
forecast so
npm install
react uh accessible
accord accordion that's the name of it
okay added one package there are some
warnings but you can ignore that
the second one is
npm install react
uh select
async
paginate uh this one
this one has some warning issues or
compatibility issues actually because
it's optimized for the older version of
react it's going to be updated
eventually i try this library it works
uh as expected so but don't worry if you
get the warnings and you will most
likely if you if you're installing this
on your new versions of react just use
the force flag in order to be able to
install it
but don't worry yeah you can use other
this is like a wrapper library for react
react select
package
it gives you some additional options so
that's why i'm using this
and that's it now we can npm
run start
and start
start our application
it starts the development server
localhost 3000
and we have our application up and
running that's nice
okay
so
the first thing is first to explain you
what we are going to have on this
website on these applications we will
have three components the first one is
going to be search on very top and we
have two widgets one is for the current
weather and the second one or the third
one is for the forecast so let's create
a new folder here new folder and name it
components
components cool and the first one let's
build the search
new folder
call it
search
okay
and in the search let's add new file
search.js okay
so this is going to be a component that
is going to be using the async paginate
[Music]
package that we just installed okay
so create
const
search
and let's just create a dummy component
to integrate it so return
hello
and export
default
search
okay
and we can use this component inside of
our address
component let's remove this boilerplate
code
and we need to import
our search component let's remove the
logo
so
import
search component here okay
and we have our hello
okay nice
so i want to add some of the global
styles to
to our application so let's create a
container
here for the class name
container and i just want to
add some maximum width so it's not full
width of the of the window so i can go
to app.css remove all this boilerplate
code and just add the container
container and add max width
of
1080. and add a margin so it's centered
so margin is
uh
20 pixels and auto so
top and bottom 20 pixels left and right
auto so it centers the the container
okay nice
now i want to add couple of global files
so global styles so that we don't have
to worry about that later
so for the font family i want to remove
this default one and let's add roboto
and there's a fallback ariel
and set that as important also i want to
add a background color i don't want i
don't like
the white one so use the uh d
d5
uh
d4
d4
yes that's the one
let's just preview that
nice
okay
this looks like it's cloudy okay so we
can proceed to build our search
component
so let's close the app index everything
so inside of the of this
search let's
import
the only component that we're going to
use which is asympaginate so
async page this is the name of the
component
and this component is going to have
couple parameters so first one let's put
the placeholder the placeholder is going
to be search for city because we want to
search for cities to show
to display the weather for it
now
the second parameter is the bounce time
uh we don't want to fetch the api uh and
call the back and every time that we
press the key so we want
i mean we want but you know if
somebody's pressing very fast
it's gonna send a bunch of requests so
here we are adding some d bounds for 600
milliseconds
then for the value we're gonna add
search
but
we will create the search
variable using geostate hook so const
search
and set search this is for updating that
variable set
search okay
and we'll use use statehook for it okay
and the initial state of this variable
is going to be null
okay
then on on change method we want to
update this value and we want to emit
that
to the parent
to the app.js where we will fetch
you know the weather
weather data and pass that to two other
two widgets
so on change
we'll call
candle
on change
okay let's create that one
okay
console on change
this will retrieve search data the data
that we entered into as inpaginate
component
and
what we want to do this is going to be
very simple we will use the set search
method to update our search and we will
use
search data for it
and then we will we will have
the the event
the function actually which which is
passed from the parent component
let's call it uh on search
change
and we will just call that
and pass the data that we got from the
input
okay
cool
now what we need to do is we need to go
and to
add that
that event so go to
app.js and on the search
add the
on search change and add the handle
on
search
change
okay
so
this can be static right now so we don't
we can implement that later so just add
const
candle on search change
and it will receive search
data
it needs to be fed error function okay
and just we can just close a log that
for now okay
search data okay cool we can continue
implementing the things that
yeah so as you can see we have built
already
uh
this
uh this autocomplete search but it
doesn't work because we haven't
implemented anything yet
so what you need to do
is
when we start searching we need to fetch
the fetch the data
and
how we can do that
is uh we first
okay so how we do that is
let me see uh we need to call uh the
method
for
loading the options so here we have an
additional load options property and
because we are adding because we are
loading the the properties for the input
uh
through async request so we don't have
anything downloaded uh previously and we
when we type in some some characters
like for example we are searching for
london we type in lond and then it's
searching this api to find all the
cities with that prefix so we need to
code that so the name of the
of the method is going to be load
options and now let's create a
const the name of the method is load
options and this one
it will
retrieve the input value so this is the
value
that we are typing into the input
and we will use that value to pass into
the to the fetch method to the url and
to get the data okay
uh so
this is the this is the
uh
this is the api that we use to search
the cities so here what we can do is we
can go and copy copy all this
uh code and paste into our application
but let's create a additional file for
this we don't want to store it inside of
this search component so let's place it
in the source folder new file and call
it api.js
like like so okay
so what we can do is we can just
copy the options
and the fetch method and we will extract
the url
so inside of the api
let's export the options
and call the options as
geo
api
api
options so what is inside of these
options is the method that we use for
the fetch and like i said uh in the
headers there is a key and host so the
key is the one that you need to get into
your account
and the host is uh same for for for this
api for everybody
now we can what we can do is we can
create a constant
export
const geo
api url
and
use this one
schwann geo
and
paste it here
okay
now we can use this fetch
we can save this file go to search
and now we can use that to fetch
so what we need to do is we need to
return new fetch
and we can import now the url so this
url and we can import the geoapi options
so
import
from
from api
okay from api and we need to import uh
url and geoapi options
so these are the parameters that we need
to pass into the fetch method
okay so here
i can add the
backticks so it's easier to
to implement the variables so first is
the
api url then we use cities
and then what i want to do is if you go
to
to the api itself and if you check the
parameters
you have the mean population parameter
which is optional but with this
parameter we can limit and filter out
the small places if you're going to
search for bigger cities you can enter
like a million uh
people in in the city and it will give
us much better search so that's
something which i'm which i'm which i
want to do so set the mean
population to a million users
90 users million uh
million
population okay
and then we want to add a name prefix
so for this one we want to enter
whatever we get from this search change
so
okay actually from this input value
let me format
document so it's nice and
okay so that's it series we get the mean
population the name prefix okay
and once we get the fetch then we want
to map our response to the json because
we get the
uh we don't get the mapped when we're
using fetch we don't get mapped right
away using the json and then we're just
logging out response and we can see what
we get
uh later on we can map this uh to to
to match the format that we need for the
async paginate
component
so let's test it out
if i open up our app
okay let's see option is not defined yes
because we haven't
implemented the options here
okay these are the options
again these are the options for the
fetch method
cool
and now if i open up the console
okay
if i type in
belgrade let's say
uh we get the data but we also get some
errors let me just see one one at a time
so we get the data the actual data
uh yeah
okay this is the initial data
uh let me see what is the error a load
option
should be an object with an options prop
okay yeah the issue with this is
uh that we are not providing the correct
format to the to this input so that's
why it's giving the error and it's
giving us this loader but if i check the
network
i can see that the fetch is actually
actually successful so we fetch let's
see the headers in the headers we said
we said uh this is the url prefix is
belgrade and for the pale for the
preview
if i open the data we got two results
and the first one is belgrade serbia and
the second one is belgrade district so
it works but the format for this input
is not correct so let let us fix that
the format that it requires is an object
array array of objects with the value
and label properties
so inside of this second
then
we can format that so
return
an object which actually has an options
parameter and this options parameter
needs to have a array of objects so we
will use response.data
and we can map that
okay we don't need a semicolon so what
we get here is name of the location or
city however you want to call it
city
and then we will return an object here
we will have a value
and a label
and for the value what we need we need
latitude and longitude in order to
implement the weather api let me show
you so if i go to
to the services and for the apis let me
just show you what is the required
uh for the current feather let's say
if we check the api call we need to pass
in the api key the one that we got when
we registered and we need to pass the
latitude and long longitude so these two
parameters we get from the geo api
so that's why we need to store
let me close that so that's why we need
to store the value of latitude and
longitude
and we get that
if i open up the console
again
and open up the network tab
again let's type in belgrade
let me open up uh
you have exceeded the limit per second
okay
i have basic plans so you need sometimes
to type in
slower
build grade let's let's type in again
okay let me refresh
now let me open up the network
okay now we got it
because i'm on free plan so it's limited
you cannot send unlimited number of
requests per minute
but if we open up
uh this data we can see that
latitude and long longitude we have
these parameters so
let's let's copy them
so for the value we got the
we can use backticks
and we will use city
dot latitude
and add a space
and
the second one is
city
city dot
longitude
it's hard to pronounce for me
okay
so and later on we can extract this from
this value and the label is something
that user can see or you whoever is
using the application so again use the
backticks
and
use the city let's use the city dot
we can use the name of the city so
here belgrade and the country code
city dot
name comma
city.country
code
okay
see and that should be now correct
format let me format the document
okay let's try now
let me clear the console if i type in
belgrade
it's searching
let me refresh again
and as you can see finally we get the
name of the city and the code of the
country so if we select that
uh we have selected the first value and
as you can see on our in our code
we are calling the on change
unchanged we are calling the handle on
change we are passing the data we are
setting the new value and then we are
calling the answer change which has been
passed from the app.js file
and that
method is just logging out the the the
value that we're getting here
so that's pretty much what we wanted to
to get from from the search
just to get the latitude and long
longitude from uh from the cities that
we want now we can create new applica a
new component
and the first one can be the current
feather so we'll have like i said two
two components two widgets the first one
is gonna show the current feather and
the second one is gonna show uh the
forecast for uh seven days if available
so let's create new components so add
new folder name it
current
current dash
weather okay
cool
and then add a new file
current
weather
dot js
and we will have a style file here as
well new file
current
dot css
okay
now let's import this the style first
import
current
feather.css
okay and let's create a dummy component
so that we can integrate that into
import that inside of the app.js file
and start building so const
currents
rather
equals
header function and then just export we
need to return something here
return just hello
and then export default export
default current weather
okay
now we can import that into app.js file
import current weather from
from the components current weather and
then just
place that component in the return
okay
so we should get hello yes here it is
so here uh we will use a little bit of
css in order to style this nicely but
stick around with me if you if you hate
styling you you probably shouldn't be
doing a front end so yeah there's going
to be more a little bit more of css so
let's remove uh hello so this is
basically going to be like a box small
box and it will just display uh
the
you know the details for the current uh
weather
so let's add
let it div which is going to be a
wrapper
and add a class name of weather
right there okay
and here uh we'll have two sections the
first one with the temperature and the
second one the bottom one uh with other
details so add a div on top
and that one will have class name
exactly like that top
okay
so here on top you will have
uh
two paragraphs actually
two paragraphs the first one you'll have
the name of the city let's call it let's
build now static
and then we can implement the api
belgrade
and description
sunny
and let's add the classes as well
so let's have the class name for city
and a class name
for
weather
description okay
and then on the right side we will have
an image
that will represent what is the
uh the weather like so it's nice and it
has nice graphical representation
so let's
place an image and
let's add an alt
weather you need to to be careful about
the accessibility
add a class name
of weather
weather icon and for the source
uh we need actually
uh i have downloaded of
icons for for this open weather api and
this will be available in the folder
along with uh on github with the
complete code base so you can download
there and follow along with me so and
this needs to be included into the
public folder so let me do that
so for me that's in downloads
let me show you it's in downloads so i
will copy this folder
and go to the public folder open that in
file explorer
and just paste
so this folder contains all the
all the states that we have for the
weather so it will be available in the
github repository so you can download
and use this exactly the same ones but
you can use different ones as long as
you follow the naming convention here
you know when when it's sunny it's 0 1 d
dot png and so on so we can use that one
for a static one
okay so the source is
icon
icons slash
01d dot png
okay okay let me see and yes we got that
cool
and i think i think that's it so
we get we have the name of the city
description we have the weather
yeah now let's apply some styles to it
so let me close
all others
and let me open up the css so the first
one let's add some styles to the weather
this is a this is a wrapper so
let me just make sure it's spelled
correctly okay so add a width of 300
pixels
and let me just see if it's connected
properly i always like to you know
uh to make sure that everything works
correctly before i get
too far into developing right
uh border radius
set the border radius to 6 pixels so
this should be
a nice dark box so set the box let's add
a little bit of box shadow so set
10 pixels this is uh these are the
parameters for the box shadow minus 2
pixels
20 pixels
set here to 2 pixels
and set the rgb we want it to be
transparent black so
0 0 0
and 30
this is a standard
value for the box shadow
and you can see it adds a little bit of
separation
add a color this is going to be a dark
dark box so add a color which is white
and the background color
333
[Applause]
okay
nice let's add a little bit of margin so
it's centered
margin 20 pixels on top so it's
separated from the input
and auto on the right side zero on the
bottom and the auto on the left side
yeah so now it's on the center of the
page okay
now let's style the
the top
top of the of the
um oh let me just see if like
this top actually needs to image needs
to be inside of the top so yeah
okay
and we need to have
a div around the paragraphs because i
want to use the flexbox in order to
you know to align them
so use a div
or you can use a span whatever you want
okay let's format the document
cool
okay so for top i want to display that
as flex
display
flex
justify content
space
between so they are on the edges
and align them in center
line center okay
okay nice we'll add a little bit of
padding here uh
on the weather so it's not like that so
add a padding
and a padding uh zero on top 20 pixels
20 pixels and 20 pixels okay
that's more like it
okay
now let's try style the city
that's the name of the class
city
so for the city let's leave it
let's leave it white everything should
be white on this dark background so font
weight
600 so it's it's bold one size 18 pixels
line height set it to one so it's really
close to the bottom
the bottom description
and uh
margin reset
to zero so it's one next to each other
letter spacing
set the layer spacing to one pixel
okay
let's see the result okay
that's nice
now for the description
let me copy paste
the class name
okay
now set the font weight here to be
a little bit slimmer so 400 one size
this should be smaller supporting pixels
40 pixels line height
to be
one same as the city and for the margin
against that reset it to zero so there
is no space
on top or the bottom
okay so they are next to each other
okay
uh now let's
style the weather icon
we just need to set the height
i mean the size here so set the width to
be 100 pixels
100 pixels
and yeah that should do it
okay
let's now continue on building so let's
build now so this is the top part let's
build the bottom part
bottom
actually
add a class name of bottom
and here
add a paragraph with a class name of
temperature
so this one will uh will be showing the
actual temperature so
18
degrees of celsius so i don't have
i don't know how to write a degree so
degree
celsius so so use so let me just google
that and copy paste
okay i can copy the symbol here
okay
nice
temperature uh then below the
temperature i mean next to the
temperature on the left side is going to
be temperature on the right side
there are going to be details so add a
div with a
class name of
details
and here
let's add div
and we will have rows so we will have
label and then the value so add a class
name of
parameter
row and inside of the row you will have
a label and then we'll have a value
so for the first one the very top one we
will just have uh the label so span
class name
parameter label
parameter
dash label and here we will say say
details
then
create another row
in the second row
for the label
i'm going to create fields
like
and for the fields like we want to add a
value to it so parameter label and the
second one is parameter value
value and the feels like could be
anything like
22 degrees
of celsius so let's
copy this
because i know how you write this
character
okay let me let me preview that
okay nice
feels like we need uh
we actually uh
we will actually separate this this will
be styled using the flex so it will be
separate right now it looks like it's uh
it needs spacing so but let's leave it
until we use the css to fix this
so
now we'll we will just copy paste
uh this exact row and add additional
fields so what i want to display next so
i want to display basically almost all
the fields that are necessary that we
have available on the open weather api
so
add a wind
and
i mean wind can be anything i don't know
two meters per second
then add another one
uh the humidity
humidity goes in percentages so i don't
know 15
percent
add another row
and for this one let's add the pressure
pressure
at a value
it goes in pascals i think yeah
now what you want to do is we want to
style this
so let me just see what we have
yeah this looks solid but we need to
style it looks more much more nicer okay
okay so let me first before i proceed
for my document i like everything to be
nice and nicely formatted
okay so here the first one is the uh
actually
i think we can use the bottom one
sorry
i i think we can use the bottom styling
to apply that to top top styling to
apply that to bottom as well because i
want it also to be display flex to
justify content space between and to
line them
centrally so yeah
and as you can see it looks better so i
just want to make this much bigger and
this a little bit smaller and separated
so let's do that
okay the first one is temperature
temperature
so
set the font weight
to be bolder 600
font size to be real really large so 7
not 707
to the auto
okay a letter spacing
minus 5 pixels i want this to be really
really dense
and margin 10 pixels
on top and bottom and the left right to
be zero
and this is uh
this is very noticeable so
that's something that you want the first
the first thing that that everybody
who's looking for the temperature
details is looking for uh temperature
that's the most important thing so
that's why it's the largest here
and it's most noticeable
okay so for the details i think
yeah it's name details
set the width to be a hundred percent so
to take the rest the rest of the
uh the rest of the space and add a
little bit of padding to the left side
to 20 pixels
okay
nice
now let's start style the rows so the
class name is parameter row
so we want to display that as well flex
and to justify content
space between
so that we have separation between the
labels and the values
like that
okay
now let's style the labels and the
values
parameter label
and for the label align them to left
font weight to 400 this is a default
just reset that and font size
to be a little bit smaller to 12 pixels
okay
that's much more nicer
then for the
parameter value
okay
align them to right
right okay
font way this one this needs to be a
little bit bolder so it's more
noticeable the value
and the font size to 12 pixels
okay
that's nice and the last thing is which
i want to do is i want to add a little
uh border
border on the details so
on the top one so
what about what i can do is i can go to
details on top
add a class here for this one
save that and then what i can do
is i can go and add a border bottom two
parameter what is the name of it
parameter label okay
parameter label dot top
and border
bottom so it's separated one pixel solid
white let's see how that looks
uh yeah
i mean we can remove it we can leave it
however we want it
but maybe i don't like it so let's
remove that
let's remove the top
i think without the border is much nicer
like like so
okay so now we have static uh
current weather widget now what we want
to do is we want to implement the real
data and once we select something from
this
input search we want to see that
so let's do that
so what we want to do is we want to go
into adjacent file
and
on the address file and
start searching here for the data that
we have
so what we need to do first is we
we need to use the search data but
if you if you check the console let me
see
if you check the console we get the
object and here we get the label and we
get the value so we need to split the
value and get the uh
we need to get these two values in order
to search this is the location value yes
let
latitude and longitude
so
what we can do is we can search data dot
value
and we can split that
so split that with the space character
and store that
in two variables the first one
is let me see what we are
storing the first one is the latitude
and the second one is the long longitude
so first one is it's going to be a lat
uh latitude and second longitude okay
so now we have the values
for the location
and we need to fetch it so
let's check the api to see what is the
url
so we need to go to
open weather api
we can go to the current feather
and we can just
copy the url
let me open the app here
so
because we are gonna fetch the two uh
two api calls the first one is going to
be for the current feather and the
second one is going to be for the
forecast we're going to use the promisol
in order to fetch the both of these so
how we're going to do that so let's
create just two fetches and store them
into variables and pass that to the
array of the promise at all so first one
call the current
weather
patch
and use the fetch method
and here we need to pass
we need to pass the url that we just
created
so but
i think the smarter thing would be to
create
a constant
in our folder for the api
and export this
so go to api
and
export
const
weather
api
url
okay
and we will need key as well so let's go
take the key
go to
my api keys and take the key
so x
export const
weather
api key
okay
nice
you can save that and now we can use
here so
we can
we need to import that first on top
import
the driver url from
api
let me just see
oh actually it's in the same folder so
it's from api
and we need to import the
api key
api key here
okay then instead of this
api key we can replace
and put our api key
weather api key
and then instead of this
latitude we can put our actual uh
variables that we got latitude and
longitude
and that should form
our fetch so first we have the base url
then we have the weather
then we have latitude longitude and the
a uh ape app id actually this is a
shorthand work app id
and that's the first uh
fetch the second one needs to be for the
forecast so let's go and take that one
so let me open up
uh
my plan my plans and the second one is
the forecast
and we can take api call here as well
can close this we don't need it anymore
and
okay let me see
and i can paste it here
i can use this one to create another
variable and this one is going to be
uh for
forecast fetch
and we're fetching the same url uh
different is that we are using forecast
now instead of the weather
everything else is the same
okay
and now what we can do is we can use
promise
promise dot all and pass an array of
these two so let's pass the first
current weather
the order is important here because in
order that we are sending the promises
uh the return is going to be in that
same order because we are going to get
back the array as well
and the second one is going to be a
forecast fetch
and
then inside of then we we need to call
async function
we will get response
here we need to map
what you're getting
and we'll get
in the first one we will get
response
zero
dot json we need to call the json method
in order to to map the
response so we need to use a weight
and store it inside of the variable so
use whether
no but the response
name of the of the constant and we can
copy paste that to create a second one
but we will use the
thus the second or the index one
and for that one is going to be forecast
response
for cast response okay that's cool
now what i want to do is uh i want to
create
uh hooks two hooks
to store
these two so get a hook named
current
weather
okay i see that i have a typo current
widow fat it needs to be fetch
fetch and current feather fetch here
okay this is the right one
okay
so current feather
and the set current weather set
current
weather this is the first hook
you state
okay
and that imports use state let me see
yeah it implied here
and the value of the initial value is
going to be now
and let's copy paste that the second one
is going to be
the forecast
and the method for updating that
variable is going to be set forecast
forecast okay
now what we can do
is we can update
once we get the responses and once they
are mapped to a json we can update them
so set current weather
set current weather to the weather
response
okay
and
set the forecast
to the forecast response
the only thing which i want to add i
want to extend the data that we're that
we are sending and saving here because
uh
the data that we're getting from the api
doesn't contain the label that we're
displaying displaying displaying here
like abu dhabi ae so we are just getting
like the city uh the country sorry so
but i want to display exactly the same
as it's here so in order to do that we
can use the information that we got from
geo uh api uh database so and extend our
our objects to pass that so what we can
do is we can just add a city parameter
and
use the search data
search data
dot label and this label
is coming from this search here
so here we are creating this label
where we add a city name and city
country code actually country code not
city country code but country code code
of the country
so let's extend it
like like so and
here just
let me use a spread operator
to create a new object from from these
two
and now we have the city for both of
these
okay
and we want to at the end if this fails
we want to catch
and we want to cancel log
okay
and that's it uh
in order to test if this works let's
just log
these two variables to see do we get the
information that we need so we need to
get the current weather and the forecast
console.log
current weather
and console.log
forecast okay
and let's go and search
okay for now it's now let me refresh
okay let's type in again belgrade
let's select belgrade
and as you can see uh we get to
get back
the first one is from the line 28 which
is the current weather
so we get the current weather as you can
see we get all this feels like feels
like humidity temperature and all that
and the second one contains the list
which is the
which is the forecast for the future
days
so it works correctly
okay
now what i want to do is i want to pass
the data to
to our current weather and then display
that instead of
this dummy data
okay
so here we can add uh
data
and pass in
for the current feather is going to be
this current feather
variable
and we can check if that exists then
show the the widget it doesn't exist
don't show anything
so so that we are
sure that
if we are inside of the component that
we don't have any errors
so
we can do this like this
so inside of the current feather we need
to
huh we need to get a data
like like so
you can save this you can save this and
now we can
now we should go and uh replace
replace the things that we have there so
okay
let me just format the document before
proceed
and yeah
now we can work so let's first do the
top part
okay
uh for the top part we actually are
adding
this city uh label which which could be
a location but yeah
so call it data.city
and for the weather
description
let's check the api
we can check the network as well
and actually network has been
clear cleaned off so
for the description
let me see
it's inside of the weather
zero and description broken clouds okay
that's the current weather
here
so
go to data
dot weather
zero
dot description
okay let's save that up
and let's see we have broken clouds even
though
uh the image is not
changed yet so let's change that as well
so we get the icon as you can see here
which we can use to load
the image so
here
let's add the expression
let's add
the backticks
remove the double
double quotes
and then instead of this name we want to
have this dynamic
and this is going to be data dot same as
here just
the last property is going to be
uh
icon
yeah
and now as you can see we get the cloud
as well so if we type a different city
like london
london okay it took some time to you can
see that actually london is the same
weather as well so
let's see
miami
it's it's nicer there so yeah
cool
so
yeah let's back to belgrade let's
implement
the rest of the
properties
so
that's
uh that completes the top part now we go
to details let's open up the bottom part
okay
for the bottom part first one and most
important one is the temperature
so what we
need to do is go to data dot let me see
what was the name of it
name and the temperature
okay uh i think that one thing
so one thing i forgot as you can see uh
the units here are not in celsius are in
fahrenheit so how you can do that is you
can
you you can go to the urls
and here
after the api you can add the units that
you want to have so
you just you would just add units equals
metric
and here also
units equal metric okay
now we should get
uh the units in different formats so
let's see
open up here
main temperature
okay let me refresh everything
okay
upgrade
open up
as you can see it's 21 now
we need to round this because we don't
want to show it like that so but yeah
it's so it's in main and temperature
go to data
dot
main dot temp
and i want to use
the method round in order to
to round that value so use the
math.round
okay
let's see okay that's 21 now
and for the details feels like
so it's in the same
main
so basically the same as we did here
math.round
okay
data.main dot feels like
just replace the temperature it feels
like
and that's feels like it's 22.
the next one is the wind
so data dot let me see where is the data
for wind
it's here wind.speed
data.wind.speed
okay
it's nice
uh for community
data dot
i think the community is on the main as
well yes main humidity
the
main dot humidity
and the last one is pressure
i think it's also under domain beta dot
mean dot
pressure probably
pressure that's that's right
and if i say that
it should give me all the informations
okay nice so let's let's test it out so
if i go and search for paris
i recently been into paris so
unfortunately it's broken clouds so
let's try
barcelona
okay i'm trying to find something where
is uh sunny but yeah it looks like it's
it's cloudy everywhere in europe yeah
but you can see
it feels like it's 30 so it's updating
everything and this looks correctly
this looks nice so what we want to do
next is we want to uh
we want to build the second widget uh if
i go to the app.js file here we are we
build the search bar
we build the current weather and the
next thing which which i want to do is i
want to build the forecast okay
so let's do that
let's create new components
inside of the components folder
new folder name that
forecast
and add a new file
forecast okay
actually the file needs to have the js
extension
shares and i think for this one we will
also have a little bit of styles so add
new file
forecast dot css
cool
so let's build
the dummy component so that we can
implement that into
api
into the app uh component sorry
a const
forecast
and it's
just export default
for default forecast
and just return something
like
hello okay
now import that in the abjs file
below the current weather
so just call the forecast
and import forecast
next to the search
so import
forecast like so
let's test if it works yes it works it's
here
so here
in this component we will have a days
like
and uh accordions and you can click on
the accordion on the on the box and it
expands and show you the more
information more details about a
specific date and what are the details
of the weather
so let me close all the
all the other components all the other
files and open up a forecast.js file
okay
so
let me remove the hello
and here we will use that
that
accordion component that we installed
oops
let's remove that at an empty
tabs and
first thing on top i want to add a label
which will say uh daily so daily
forecast placement either add a class
name of title and
add a
daily label
okay i forgot to add here
parentheses
okay
so and then below that add accordion
accordion it auto imports it for me from
react accessible accordion
on top
and
uh i want to pass a property which is
called
allow zero expanded so this one uh
allows
allows uh
all the accordion to be closed if you
allow zero expanded so it means
basically all according can be closed
otherwise one of the accordion needs to
be opened up
okay
uh so for the forecast uh we are already
getting the data we can pass that in so
here we get the forecast data and we can
implement right data right away so we
don't have to do the dummy data so what
we can do is we can check if the
forecast data is there we can pass in
the data
otherwise don't display that that
component and inside of the forecast we
will receive
the data okay
cool
now inside of the accordion
uh
we need to loop through that data to the
through the list that we are getting so
let me just open up so we are getting
the list and these are the days of the
forecast and we need to look through
these uh days and get
the details similar like we are doing
here
but this is just the forecast you know
okay so on the top
uh
open up the accordion
korean item
okay
so and we want to
use the data
that we got
and loop through the list
data.list dot and we want to just
display the seven days that's it so use
the splice zero
seven okay
nothing else and we want to map that
here we will have
item and index because we don't have
index for the list and we need to use
the index for the keys
okay
okay
so here
we need first to add
item heading so it's called accordion
item heading
let me see if it's
yeah it's or imports it so the first one
we need we need to have the two items
inside of the accordion the first one is
according item heading and the second
one is accordion item panel so this is
something that you see
when the recording is not collapsed when
it's collapsed uh when you click on it
you get the expanded part which is uh
according item panel
so the second one is
accordion item panel let me see
this one
okay
heading
but we need to have one parent that's
what it says so
one parent item so we can use the
according item as a parent
okay here
and then we can place these two
inside of it okay nice
coding item
uh but we don't have coding item
imported
so let me import that uh it should be up
imported from the
from this one imports so it doesn't have
to be separated
separately imported so according item is
here
actually it's not
accordion has been imported according
item heading according item and
according
accordion item panel as well okay cool
here let me format that
okay nice
now
for the according item we need to add a
key
and again i'm gonna use the index
idx
and for the heading we need to place
accordion item button that is the name
this is required to do you cannot do it
without it
accordion item button
uh
item
button
let me just see
okay let me import that
as well
including item button
and then here
you can just add a hello
just for
testing so let me just test it if i have
imported everything correctly and
there's no errors yes as you can see
it's uh it gives us this daily okay i
have a typo here used to be daily
we have this label and we have
uh
seven hellos for seven days one two
three four five six seven okay nice
uh now what what i want to do is i want
to create here
uh
the title basically the the day name
and uh the show the the image of a day
and show the weather the the temperature
the max and minimum temperature and once
you expand the accordion you we will
show the deplete uh details like like
pressure uh and you know wind uh and all
the humidity you know and all other
properties
so here create a div
add a class name
of daily
item
okay
and then on the left side we'll have an
image
again
add an else
with a
weather string
add a class name
icon
small
and add a source
which is the most important one right
so
uh and the source is going to be again
in the icons
and it's going to be the same as we did
there as we did in the in the current
weather so
but here we are
accessing that from item
item
let me just open up
we can we can reuse some of the code
weather
zero icon.png okay we can reuse this one
so item dot
dot weather
okay
let's save that
okay we get the broken image
let me just check again
icons
item icons
weather zero and here is the icon
okay
let me just log to see if we get
if you are getting the right data so
inside of the
weather forecast we have the weather
i'm going to actually have the main
main
and no it's inside of the weather
weather
and inside of the icon
okay and what we are getting see it's 10
and okay maybe you don't have that icon
for barcelona
let me see 10n uh let me open up the
icons
we have that actually
oh let me see what's happening
and let's see what is the url maybe the
url is wrong icon stand png
okay yeah we have these curly braces
curly brace actually so
this one
that's broken our url
okay
let's try now again
belgrade inside belgrade
because belgrade never let us down nice
we get the images
okay
i'll open up the console so we can
reference to it
the second thing which i want to add i
want to add the forecast
you know which is the days so
add a label
and a class name so it it will say
friday saturday sunday and so on
last class name
day
and i want to create a
array of days so here let's create an
array
call it a week
days and add
an array
and let's
call first monday
it is tuesday
with
wednesday
third thursday
friday
saturday
and sunday
okay
that's nice
now we need to first determine what is
the day in a week so if we are on
wednesday if today is wednesday we want
to get the forecast for thursday friday
saturday sunday and so on so first
create a variable day in
a week
and we get that by new date dot get
day
method okay
that's cool
and then what we want to do is we want
to
determine day in a week so
and get a number so this returns a
number so if it's a wednesday it will
return like three and then we want to
cut off this part
the first part
and append it concatenate on the on here
so we will have uh array with thursday
friday saturday sunday monday tuesday
wednesday
that's what we want to do so how to
achieve that is we use weekdays dot
slice
slice doesn't uh
doesn't change the original array
and we want to take uh the first the
starting point is date
we have a typo here day in a week
the in a week okay
so first uh the starting point is day a
week and the second one is the length of
this array
so weekdays
dot land
and then we want to concatenate that
and use the
again weekdays
so concatenate the first part
weekdays dot slice
zero
day in a week
okay
and that that should do it
for my document
and we can log in
you can log that to see if it works so
console. but we haven't created
variables so create a variable cost of
forecast
days let's say
and assign there and let's log the
forecast days so today is
thursday
so let's see if if it works correctly
so friday saturday sunday monday
tuesday wednesday thursday so it works
correctly so the next day tomorrow is
friday
yeah
happy day
okay
so
now we can implement the days here label
day and we can call the
array
user rate that we just created one that
we just created so forecast days
and oops
forecast days and add the index
the index from the from the map
okay cool
here
then
let me see how it works how it looks
okay friday saturday
nice
the next one we want to add a
description
so
add another label add a class name of
description
and here
we are accessing that via item dot
oh let me see here
uh weather description okay
here
save that
okay let's try again
let's try abu dhabi okay
clear sky we don't have any space
separation but this will be style
using css so don't worry about that and
we will have another
label call it min max
so it will show the minimum and the
maximum temperature for that day
and uh let me see
how we
get the temperature so main.temp
this is how we get the temperature so
uh so item
i mean temp but
we need we don't want the temperature
just we want minimum and the maximum so
let's open the main and we have the
minimum is here
and let's copy the
celsius
okay
and we want to round that
round
okay
and we want to
display
maximum as well
maximum should be max i think
temp max okay
okay and again
add the celsius
here
and let's format that again
and let's preview that
okay yeah now we get the values uh for
some reason i see that maximum and
minimum are the same values so
yeah something is wrong with the api but
i guess
they will fix that or not but yeah we
use the data that we got it's not our
fault but yeah you know this is these
are the maximum and the minimum values
so we get the
the icon we get the day we get the
description we get the minimum and the
maximum value
so what i want to do now is i want to
style
apply some styles so i make this a
little bit nicer
let open up the forecast.css
now let's start first from the style
from the title
uh
how we get pedal
close the other files
for the title i just want to increase
font size set it to 23 pixels
and
a little bit bolder so font
font weight to 700
okay
uh it doesn't work because probably we
haven't imported the css
yes we haven't so
import
import
forecast
for
cast.css okay
okay now it should work
oh actually
it's in the same directory so
okay
okay now daily works
okay what i want to do next is i want to
style uh the first one is
the title the second one is daily item
okay
so let me copy paste that
here
okay
daily item so set the background color
to
f5 f5 f5 so
uh
the daily item is going to be
uh is going to be like i said the panel
uh which shows you
the state when it's not clicked when
it's not expanded so it's gonna be white
almost white but once you expand it's
gonna be it's gonna have the same uh
it's gonna have transparent background
you will see
set the border radius
to 15
pixels i like border radius set the
height of 40 pixels
height to 40 pixels margin to 5 pixels
so we separate the panels
okay much nicer yeah the image is
breaking the layout but yeah you can see
how the panels are going to be
uh
displayed align item center
yeah but before that we need to create
it uh to add a display flags
okay
uh create a course add a cursor as a
pointer so so that the user knows that
they need to click
set the font size
so 14 pixels
and add a little bit of padding
5 pixels on top and bottom and 20 pixels
on left and right
yeah that looks much better okay
i don't want to save anything so
let me
style the icons now so that
it's inside of the box
so use the icon
and set the width to be 40 pixels
okay
as you can see now it's much better
okay so now let me see what's next
next is the day so
the day in a week
so set
the color
two
two one two one
two one okay the dark one
uh
for flex set the one one so what i want
uh
i want the the name
of the day and the description to take
the
uh the equal amount of uh the space and
for the icon and for the temperature to
go on the sides so that's why i'm gonna
uh set the friday day and the
description to one in one flex
so it you know spreads around
set the font weight to
600
and the margin left to 15 pixels
so it's separated from the icon
like so so you can see
right now it takes
all the space but once we set that to
the description it will split
okay
so let's take the description
description
okay set the flex
to
1 1 and let's see
and now you can see it takes uh it takes
the weight of it
flex 1 1
margin right
15
so it's moved
on the right and text align to the right
okay
that's more like it yeah
let me just format the document
and let's proceed so now let's style the
mini max the temperatures i just want to
change the color so it's a little bit
different nothing else
uh color two seven five
seven five seven five five
okay
and this will give this gray color okay
cool
that's already much nicer
okay and let's see i think that
completes that now we need to create the
accordion panel so this is the part
uh
once we click on the panel
it will expand and show show us the more
details
so inside of the accordion panel
uh let's add a grid so we'll have again
like rows and the labels
so add a div
and call it
daily
actually give it a class name first
class name
daily
details
grid okay cool
and inside of it add another deal
and this div
is gonna have a class name
uh daily
details uh grid
item let's call it like that
and here we have two labels one is going
to be
uh
the actual label in the second one is
going to be the value so label
and this one is going to be
the first one is going to be pressure
and
second one we're gonna display the
pressure so
we're getting that from item dot uh
let me just see
item.name.pressure
okay
main dot pressure
okay
let me just test this
so
we're going to re reload
page if it doesn't let's
click something else
so in right now you can see if we expand
any of the these collapsible sidebars
now sidebars but accordion sorry we get
the pressure so let's enter all the rest
of the details and let's style them
so what i want to add is i can just
copy paste discrete items and just
change the
the labels and the properties so the
second one humidity
and it's i think it's in the same
object okay it's community yes
just change the community
okay let's copy paste again
the next one is clouds
so the clouds are in
let me see
okay
they have separate
property clouds at all cool
okay
then the next one is wind speed
speed
and we can take the wind speed from wind
dot speed okay
cool
items.wind
[Music]
dot speed and it's meter per second
is the unit
there
then the next one is the sea level
c
level
[Applause]
and the sea level is inside of
main sea level okay
mean dot
c level and the units is in in meters so
okay
meters
and let's
add another one
feels like
this one is most important i think so
feels like how you feel
so it's from maine i think
i think it's from
maine
uh feels like yes
and i want to round this
round
[Applause]
and this one is in celsius so
we can remove this
we can remove this yeah i don't need
that
okay
let's try now so we can get the pressure
humidity the clouds
okay clouds yeah clouds going percentage
nine dollars percent percentages
um
pressure also goes goes in
past calls i think
i'm not sure
what is dna for pressure but yeah
um pressure
here and the humidity
uh in percentage as well
okay
okay
now we have all the information that i
want but
we need we need just to style it so
let's again let's
let's type in belgrade why not
okay all the information feels like sea
level wind speed clouds
humidity and the pressure
okay
now let's open up the styles
so
what is the name of the class that we
added a daily detail script let me just
copy paste that why not
that is the easiest way to do though to
do so without making any errors so
add a grid
row gap
zero
okay
and uh
grid column this is the gap obviously
between the columns column grid column
gap 15 pixels okay
so the gap between the the rows is going
to be zero and between the columns is
going to be you know 15 pixels
okay so
add a column gap 15.
cool
display as grid in order this to work
right
add a flex
1 1
grid template
columns to auto auto
okay
let me see how that looks
okay so we have the grid right now
and add a little bit of padding
padding to five pieces on top and bottom
and 15 pixels left and right and add a
little bit of
uh no
for the roll gap
that's it
row gap should be
zero yeah okay
now the next one should i think it
should be item oh yes daily
item
so let's copy paste that one
and align
items to center
display as flex
set the height to 30 pixels
high to 30 pixels and justify content
space between
space between okay
cool
let me check how it looks
okay we have some separation much nicer
and i think that's pretty much it we
just want to apply some of the
some of these styles uh yeah
to the labels so i want
this one to be a little bit
lighter and this one to be a little bit
darker so the labels should be you know
lighter and the values should be a
little bit darker and that should you
know that should do it so how we can do
it is
we can target it using the first child
selector so we're targeting the class
name the first child is this label the
the last child
is this one so
so first child
and the last child
but
i mean for the label okay
label and for the first child set the
color to be again seven five seven five
seven five seven five
and for this one should be a little bit
darker two one two one two one
color okay
let's add a semicolon there as well
and yeah here we have a little bit
uh
little
oh here we go a little bit darker and
here a little bit lighter so
and i think that completes let me just a
formatted document
format
this one as well and let's review what
we got
and what we built so if i refresh the
application let me close the console
what you can do is obviously remove the
all the console logs you don't want to
to leave that so right now we can search
for the city once we load the page you
don't you don't get any of the widgets
because we don't have any information
uh if you search
belgrade
because belgrade
is the closest city to me
we get details on very top like we like
we built on the first
component and the second one we get the
forecast for the friday saturday for the
seven days ahead and if you click on the
on the accordion it gets expanded and we
get the additional information so we can
open up all the accordions depending on
the day which we want to see the
information
then if you want to check for another
city let's say we want to fly to the
paris and we want to see what's where
they're going to be like there and boom
it gets up updated right away so we can
see that he's going to be very cloudy in
next day for the paris
and that's it that sums up we built this
awesome application i hope you guys
enjoy it it took quite some time to
develop this
and i hope you enjoyed it like i said
and you learned a couple of things here
and there
so yeah that's it
well that's all for this react video
thanks for stopping by and don't forget
to subscribe
code with slova
thank you for watching the entire video
to see more react tutorials click here
[Music]
you